attention comes in understanding that
Tik tok's about to blow but it also
comes in knowing that Gunna sat here
when he had 400 followers on Instagram
or that my company bner media did a
campaign called finding the next Vine
star and the winner that we chose for
that campaign was Logan Paul or that
Charlie Deo or Charlie Deo was in that
office moments before she went crazy
like I pay attention to people I pay
attention to platforms I pay attention
to why ceroid hats are hot one than two
years ago so that's fashion and music
and PE attention is the number one
asset twitch thank you for joining and
being patient I know you've been waiting
for the last 50 minutes this is podcast
with friends Chase just walked in had a
few minutes late there a few minutes
late oh man man yeah it's tough you know
street I'm not used to this no moreor
New York City is different uh episode
three of podcast with friends I'm really
excited about this three young men even
though we were joking beforehand joining
me I think I made a little bit of
mistake for episode two big shout out to
Ash and the rest of the crew that was
with me I'm going to give these three
gentlemen I actually learned from that
so what I'm going to start this episode
with is go around the horn and let
everybody have 2 three minutes to really
let the audience know who they are what
they do what they're about and then
we'll just chop it up like friends and
we'll get out of here but huge shout out
to everybody on Twitch thank you for uh
tuning in that's the other enjoyable
part of this one I was missing people
and wanted to make fresh content so this
is the format and two I've been wanting
to really stream I've got an extra thing
coming soon for everybody on Twitch but
if you're listening on the podcast
go to gary.com Twitch and make sure you
follow the channel uh I'm enjoying
everyone in here so anyway let's do this
my man why don't you tell everybody in
the audience who's watching live and
listening to the podcast the day we
launch it and for the next 5 years who
you are what you do give us three
minutes okay my name is Franklin aka the
king of trainers I am um the UK and
Europe's one of the UK biggest sneaker
bloggers um I've probably done more
sneaker content than anyone in the world
if I'm honest yeah it's just it's not on
YouTube is mainly on Instagram um I'm
the person that um JD Sports tried to
take to court over the king of trainer's
name and um and and they had to back
down um I I now currently help um a lot
of um social media people and I I
consult for aex as well aex jackets I
help open the first standard on aex shop
in London um and I just different
businesses here and there up and ups and
downs ups and entrepreneur ups and downs
when people say what you say you're an
entrepreneur yeah yeah yeah is that what
you say well to be fair I I do say it
but I am I I I would say I'm a business
person cuz you know entrepreneur
sometimes I think everyone says it yeah
everyone says it I'm 48 I just turned 48
when I when I came up the game I was
like I'm a businessman I'm a businessman
the word didn't even exist cuz
ironically back in the day it everybody
who said entrepreneur was on some not
really doing [__] then when I came up my
era the thing that kind of like I got I
had good timing where it got cool again
it was entrepreneur and it's funny to
hear you say that
like I'm a bus cuz I'm like I understand
where you're going with that cuz a lot
of people playing the part on the gr
that brings me to to to why I was going
to get everyone to guess my age on on on
on live yeah everybody take a look at
this F's face real quick guess his age
twitch I feel like anyone that says that
is
old I'm nobody young says that course oh
okay someone said 50 50 no that's B cuz
they know that he wouldn't notice how I
don't say how old I like he's got that
black d crack [__] going too that's
always winning that's always winning wow
okay how old are you I'm 44
yeah can
we come on CH give it to about to say
share your regimen man what's going on
just the happiness you grew I love that
that is the [__] regimen you you find
yourself positive yeah as much as I can
be yeah as much as I can be even though
sometimes you you had a positive parent
yeah both parents yeah my father passed
away two two
years no it's fine it's F you grew up
where in um in London London totenham to
so when you hear of riots cuz I have a
bricks to and that's and that's where I
grew up Spurs life Spurs Spurs for sure
all right man tell everybody who you are
what's up y' U I'm Chase B uh DJ
producer all around um I always call
like an Enthusiast of the culture
because it just comes with a lot uh
sneakers obviously um a big thing worldo
just the whole just the whole realm of
everything pop culture which is obious
in today's world black urban culture but
it you know I think I I I will use
culture when I'm talking about what
you're talking about I'll use pop
culture when I take on everything what
do 14-year-old white girls like about
coffee what's going on with exactly pop
culture Andor culture keep going all
right so with that um a lot of people
know me for obviously my involvement
with like Cactus Jack and everything t
with tra like the last I don't know 12
years or so yeah of course um and then
you know just other things on top of
that like um like how we talking about
businessman earlier really just like
legitim iing and actually owning things
so as me and you talked about Gary we
just started the show Ox money um the
podcast kind of just overall just
cultural
musical athletic like binding um if you
will of the sorts and all that so a show
we just started we actually launched the
first episode uh about a week and a half
ago with with with borro with Rich
climbing last night me and my friend Kim
actually uh created the whole entire
show and um we sat down rich and with
Katie and we know they just love the
idea so we partnered with them to just
deliver it in the best way possible yeah
wanted to use the platform to get as
much exposure as possible 1 plus one
equals 11 yeah and they just they just
exactly and they just helped us button
up a lot of things that um you know that
we had going you would had to learn over
two or three years they sped up the
process exactly yeah so shout out to
them for sure and um so yeah we launched
our first episode with uh with CJ stra
about a week and a half ago it's doing
amazing man he's crazy bro I'm so happy
for him for real I met him you know how
those rookie Seasons could go man he's
having like the best ironically the Jets
played the Falcons this weekend and we
reped de Ritter to the Falcons
quarterback so this is the first time
since I've owned Vayner Sports where my
my beloved Jets have to play a team that
has a quarterback that I rep that we rep
that AJ reps that Brian actually reps
he's his aent but V Sports good news Dez
big shout out you know I love you but
like good news I feel nothing I want the
Jets to destroy
Dez yeah I'm I'm Jets over everything
I'm Jets over everything everything
everything but um Stroud's been balling
I met him when Dez was working out with
Jordan Palmer out West Coast he was
still in college and I kind of walked
away saying like that kid's got it like
that good head on his shoulders man
great kid great kid so uh grew up in
Houston I grew up in Houston yeah I
lived here actually I lived across the
street for about six years literally
across the street I watched this whole
area get built it was loud as hell every
morning yeah yeah so um yeah I lived in
the building called the like right
across the
street definitely from Houston I'm back
in Houston now I'm just like kind of
back and forth like every other week
where do you really even live anymore to
be honest if you're making things happen
you're right
uh what's up everybody I'm Christian
Crosby I'd say my claim to fame is
definitely working in the NBA as an in
Arena host for Philadelphia 76ers which
is home based but I also do all the NBA
stuff so like NBA draft NBA Allstar
Weekend actually there was a NBA Allstar
it was during a slam dunk contest right
I was killing it I was doing a great job
and you were sitting uh like I don't you
were like I think first row and you were
just you were vibing you we made eye
cont eye contact a couple times and you
were just like
you're doing you're doing a [__] good
job I remember I don't know if you
remember that or not I was like I think
it I'll take that man I like thanks Gary
I think it was
Chicago I remember it very well facts
that's crazy so yeah honestly by the way
real quick for the podcast and everybody
on Twitch and for all of us can we start
making giving flowers while people are
alive a bigger thing what that was look
here they come the Goosebumps I know
what I'm saying something like I like we
don't do it enough we're quick to tell
people what they suck at Ser we're quick
to tear people down we're quick to be
envious of people moving and can't wait
for them to [__] up but why not give
love I
agree in little ways like that like I
remember that vividly that's Gary do you
really remember that I really remember
that cuz I will never forget it and like
it's crazy like that's just a random
really I really remember it and and by
the way the coolest part is and I
wouldn't say it the other thing I've
held myself accountable to cuz I so want
to give people flowers is well if I give
people flowers when I don't mean it then
it doesn't mean anything the reason I
remember it is cuz I remember it right
true because what I do for a living is
try I mean my next book day trading
attention comes out next year attention
comes in understanding that Tik tok's
about to blow but it also comes in
knowing that Gunna sat here when he had
400 followers on Instagram or that I or
that my company bner media did a
campaign called finding next Vine star
and the winner that we chose for that
campaign was Logan Paul or that Charlie
Deo or Charlie Deo was in that office
moments before she went crazy like I pay
attention to people I pay attention to
platforms I pay attention to why
corduroy hats are hot one two years ago
so that's fashion and music and people
and so the reason I remember it was cuz
I meant it right because I think you
really were doing a great job and it's
hard thank what you do that's not that
easy and to even get to be able to do it
is already real talent but you were
doing on a big stage with a lot of chaos
I remember it very well yo Gary's over
here trying to make me cry and I don't
appreciate
it that's what's up go backwards let's
go even a step deeper and then we'll get
into some other [__] sure how did you
the whole give me the real origin story
I'm going to go into how did you get
there so we got a sense of what you do
yeah so you grew up where so I grew up
in South Jersey uh um but most of my
life uh has beener Hill Camden like I
was born in Vorhees so if you're
familiar with that area so I know every
zip code in New Jersey cuz when I was
building my dad's liquor store back in
the 90s I went crazy on direct mail
sending coupons and I I was one of the
first people to have a website so I was
like wait I can send coupons close to my
dad's store right but I can send [__]
mail to Cherry Hill 2 hours an hour and
a half away 2 hours from Springfield but
I could say go to wine
library.com and so I literally analyzed
every zip B
me that's a very fun fact God that's
amazing okay so Cherry Hills so like the
Total Wine in Cherry Hills that big
liquor store like I like knew the day it
came out in 1992 and analyze how they
did you have to understand now all of
you kind of know me a little bit imagine
14 to 34 yeah and really 13 to 14 to 34
four but 14 to 30 imagine 14 to 30y Old
me having 100% of my attention to the
liquor store New Jersey business and
wine that's all I care about right it's
why I got all those bad raids up there
in my report card it's why I don't have
any story of fun in my 20s I was
religious of building the biggest liquor
store in New Jersey for my dad okay but
like where did that come from cuz like
even if even let's say your dad wanted
you to be that I'm glad I have I'm glad
you're here you know where it came from
from gratitude yeah MH yeah I was so
grateful I understood somewhere around
12 13 15 17 somewhere in that you know
Junior High middle school high school
preol somewhere along the way I realized
damn my parents are
better yeah it was deep long before we
talked about feelings I was just like my
mom is the best my dad worked I don't
really even know my dad like when I
realized it I was starting to work with
him but like my dad worked every minute
to you know I was born in the Union we
came to this country lived in Queens in
a studio the size of this room with
eight family members I'm talking really
actually like people on the floor like
the [__] that people say on come up
stories I liveed it and we didn't speak
English and [__] was hard and it was
like really a tough time in America late
'70s we were all [__] up with the
economy and so I and this might resonate
for a lot of people who are watching or
in this podcast or definitely listening
I believe the person that is most
Unstoppable in life is the person that
is lucky enough to be born born into a
family that doesn't have that much
financially in the first 10 years of
their life but they're happy as [__]
right because they're shown that
happiness has nothing to do with Finance
right that's fact if you're unhappy in a
home that doesn't have a lot you believe
cuz the world tells you money will get
you happy right if you're in a house
that is very wealthy and everyone's
happy you think it's because the money
interesting but if you're in a house
that doesn't have
much that is happy you as you grow you
just know and of course these are
generalizations when you said interest
of course do I believe there are people
I mean I have wealthy kid like do I
think there are people but you but you
know what the problem is you can't fake
environment no no you can't like the way
all of us came up and everyone you can't
fake it no right meaning like it is what
it is like you none of us can feel the
alternative I can be empathetic and
understand but I don't know what it's
like to grow up where you can sit courts
side at a game I was just trying to one
day when I'm older I can buy a ticket to
a basketball game
Courtside that didn't even run through
my [__] mind unable [__] you know
what I mean but other kids like like you
know especially in the circles I run in
now they think they should be friends
with CJ Stroud they just think that
shit's
normal you know just and so and then
everybody in between those two extremes
right so anyway how' you come up so so I
I do come from a household uh maybe some
struggle but middle class a little below
middle class it's a it was an up and
down Journey there were times good
Christmases where I was lit and then
there it was like y'all a getting
anything this year type Christmases so
um I just fell in love with the Arts I
my par my dad gave me a camera when I
was younger I was just into Visual and
acting and dancing um I'll fast forward
to I got my first car uh commercial with
Target yeah got a $5,000 check and I was
a kid like oh my God I think I was like
16 17 I was like oh my God got good face
I learned hands thank you Gary I was
like yo I can make money doing stuff
like this so then I did another
lowbudget Philly tourism commercial but
there were two Sixers dancers in the
commercial at the time I did martial
arts so I did like flips and tricks and
I was doing these flips and tricks in
the commercial and the dancers came up
to me was like yo you'd be perfect for
the slam dunk team for the Philadelphia
76ers I just wanted their
number I connected with them uh followed
up showed up to the audition I wasn't
even that good but they like the karate
that I did so and your charisma I I
wasn't even in the sports it's funny I I
just thought it was a coach in a team I
didn't realize there was community
relations marketing PR I didn't know any
of that I end up getting a job my first
game I'll never forget it I walked in
and I I just looked around and saw all
the people working I was just like I
want to be here so from that day forward
I became the super intern kid made every
mistake but never made it twice KN knew
everybody's name came early left late
that whole story right uh by the way
talk about a lost
art I'm just goingon to say I'm going to
rewind it and have repeat it the amount
of this is why I [__] with the guys and
gals that come to my team were very
selective but it's getting harder 10
years ago I could find a thousand super
interns there was unlimited kids who
were like yo I'm hungry this guy's got a
platform that I get put on and I'm
coming right real and not that I think
Jen Z is lazy and this and that it just
[__] got different yeah just want to
skip a lot of steps really and honestly
I don't judge I'm going to say this real
careful I'm not judging the kids right
now shit's just different right Zoom do
I have to the government gave everybody
money they think they can do it faster
which I respect the [__] you can go eat
[__] for five years to get on if you
think you can go get on right now right
but like the whole vibe like super
intern doesn't exist like you doesn't
exist anymore I think they're just
smarter than us and there's more options
to get things faster and they the
quickness Ginger beloved said Christian
is cute and charismatic Ginger beloved
let's
go shots getting shot man how how'd your
world go what kind of kid were you in
Houston man in Houston uh it was all
about sports where I was at everything
was about my high school was if you
weren't getting a scholarship like you
just weren't as good as everybody else
it yeah the athletes were here everybody
everybody else was everything was very
competitive so I ran track that Texas
[__] Friday night I went to high school
was the of Friday Night Lights the whole
and the basketb we went to state twice
everything was football football
basketball track we all went to State
while everybody killed in all everybody
was just amazing how was your baseball
team it was all right it wasn't it was
it wasn't but the high school down the
street from us the high school down the
street from us was had like an amazing
baseball team so everything was just
very competitive even our practices were
like full speed everything you played
Sports and that was sports sports sports
was all high school so um I actually
ended up going to Howard to run track in
DC and when I got there I was like I'm
not going to the Olympics like what am I
doing here so and like you kind of said
before about like how thing things were
just like unfathomable I had no
knowledge of like the music industry
like that like none my parents are
involved in that none of my family at
all is really involved in the music
industry so when I got to Howard I
actually uh was on a College radio
station and it just taught me so much
about just like that industry of media
and why did you do the radio you were in
I was in the School of Communications
for something totally different and um
but they offered that as like you know
kind of yeah and I would just like let
me try this out so from then I did you
always want to go to Howard uh probably
when I was like CU sophomore in high
school you were like that's the target
yes how did that day feel when you got
it and yeah so when I went to DC to
visit I had an uncle that actually lived
in DC it was my first time even going
and I got there and I was just like
something is like really special and
like different about even the way they
dress and everything I was like DC is
just like his own world it's nation's
capital just driving by the White House
every day was just like some just cool
different different and um you really
don't appreciate it until you like go
there and and leave and come back it's
like y I really did this like every
single day so um DC just taught me a lot
about just finding yourself within like
yeah and you were also in that great I
mean 18 to 22 yeah you know you got to
pick a major about yourself every hour
exactly you know it's a special time
yeah so with the radio station I started
um DJing in clubs and [__] when I was
probably like 19 years old and um whole
bunch of financial [__] happened I had
up had to drop out and I actually kind
of just ran away and moved my
grandmother had just passed away this
probably like 2011 or something like
that so I moved to uh East ARS New
Jersey and um I would just get gigs out
here in the city for like maybe $50 to
$100 a lot of times it was free just
like for the look or whatever I was
sleeping in Pen Station at a point just
to like you super internate super intern
you know some people super intern for a
company exactly other people super
intern for the market right like I super
interned for the market I sold [__] my
whole life lemonade baseball cards flea
markets my dad's liquor store like the
market was my boss I didn't have a boss
ever the world was my boss exactly yeah
like super interning for the
world we got to bring back the super
that's what you're doing you grinding y'
just grinding you know um I feel like
you know and I had no doubt at any point
when I was even asleep on the floor just
like something your grandma lived there
exactly so pass and you went into the
house yeah exactly so I would do gigs in
in the city but the PATH train or the
New Jersey Transit wouldn't start again
until like 4:00 or 5 in the morning so I
would just have to just figure it out
I'll just walk around Time Square like
[__] like that on some of that [__] on
some yeah yeah until I could get back I
would just hop trains and like do
whatever and um from there this is when
um the Darby was like really like the
Darby on 14th and um I got like an
opportunity to DJ there one night and it
turned from one night to two nights to
three nights a week and then when it
became up and down I was like my whole
[__] I was there like you were that guy
yeah I was there um up and down the one
I really miss those clubs man for real
yeah they were ionic clubs exactly yeah
that was like my whole and that's when
you were making your that's when I like
find my own as far as like being a DJ
and turned to Vegas and like whatever
you have now and then um who let's back
to flowers who were some of the homies
that saw you man DJ Clark Kent bro there
you go DJ Clark K back to flowers you
know what I mean like yeah Clark k i
I'll probably say him every interview I
I'll ever do just because um obviously I
just looked up to him so much this DJ
and yeah you know just he was a legend
already you met him and he was cool and
he wasn't like a old guy that tried to
be young like he was like old he he
stands on being like yo I'm old bro but
I'm like the tightest old
[__] yeah like he's going to be like
I'm the I'm the dopest old [__] you
ever in your life you know he never like
tried to like yeah youth down you know
to you down and he just kind of told me
he really broke down the game of how you
you can do it make money like even aside
from clubs and like gigs or whatever to
like really Enterprise yourself as a d
this meet these kind of exactly Shake
everyone's hand hello to everyone I saw
some people in the comments on Twitch
say memorizing everyone's name is real
which is super hard for me I'll tell
you bro names is real hard for me but
moments as you saw with Chris like I'll
tell you [__] that like that is my
superpower I'll bring up crazy [__]
especially if I see someone that I know
I know I'll like immediately be like yo
saw you in Boston 13 years ago when you
sneezed right oh Gary me I'm like what's
his
name a real GI though it's a real good
because audio and visual I got it audio
and visual I got it yeah but it's why I
don't have reading comprehension
something with names just doesn't anyway
nonetheless yeah yeah so no definitely
uh credit to DJ car for um you know he's
my if I said to you like what was the
moment where you knew you crossed over
from like the come up to that next stage
which one Pops in mind man I just really
cuz I know it's Millions Pebbles to get
to a boulder I people ask me all the
time like 87 different things I can tell
you but like what's one that you think
was a moment I feel like uh so I signed
a record deal in 2018 in Columbia and um
just even at that point I never really
thought of myself as like putting my own
records out and put music out or
whatever but even to just when I when I
was on that radar I was like yo you're
much bigger than like what you think you
are right now and have the I basically
had every single leg that call and just
like you should put an album out yeah so
at that point I was like oh this is
bigger than me just being presid at like
at a Travis show or in a club it was
like Market the market was something
much bigger yeah so at that point I was
like all right how do I shift this into
like something much more than what I'm
doing right now man cool um yeah growing
up in London Tottenham um I grew up yeah
when Tottenham was different a little
different very different yeah got a
little gender fi yeah yeah very
different we know what you're saying
indeed indeed so um yeah man I mean I I
grew up at a time unfortunately it was
it was quite quite violent I lost a few
friends um so even like in the early '
90s I would be in New York a lot yeah so
I'll be staying in Brooklyn Flatbush
with my auntie just to kind of get out
of trouble from in in London you know
and just let it calm down yeah yeah it
was crazy so it was like that bad it was
it was really bad like you had to go to
America to hide yeah but for me it was
just it was it was the fact that I just
had a lot of friends and my best friend
got murdered and um it just kind of yeah
that's a
experi yeah so I was like that's tough
yeah yeah so you know from then um I
mean and for me in terms of like
business I knew from 15 I went to work
for myself but I had to do the
university rout for my parents yeah for
all the kids that are listening and
watching on Twitch and even for you
youngsters like again when we were com I
just turned 48 44 you said you know like
it wasn't like that yeah like at 15 when
we both felt it it wasn't as obvious it
is for everybody right now exactly I see
there was no it for you there might have
been an internet internet was popping no
like the internet changed everything
like like you couldn't do anything there
was like no there was not a sing every
single influencer that you know that's
under 20 making money there was not one
of those that existed when I was 16 zero
not one that's it the most famous
business person for us coming up was
Bill Gates and he was the nerdiest
looking dude on Earth and it was like I
don't want to be that like if money
comes with that and you kind of thought
you had to be like this genius to even
yeah it was like so dork right right it
was like dorks like like and it was like
and not that like Bill Gates is a dork
but that was like the image that's what
in cool culture it was Street it was
it's not what hip-hop is now where it's
fashion this it was if you were not hard
you weren't in yeah that's back to even
like where people grew up do do you know
that people that came up hip hop in the
80s and 90s if they had an auntie in the
hood but they grew up in middle class
they would tell people they were from
the they would be like I'm from from
such and such because you're just like
you couldn't say you were from like it
was that much the currency hard and
rough nothing else not creative not nice
not nothing just H yeah that's how
London that's def how London was yeah
that's how London was um and then yeah
so you know from from school had to
University went down University and then
straight from University I graduated to
like 2000 2003 I I worked in my own
businesses I had an installation company
property Investment Company done well in
property quote unquote called I made a
million in property that's what that was
my dream to just make a million right
Made It by about 26 2 let me say back to
kids that are like 44 and up mhm a
million was
like and now was like a billion oh
million like that was like a billion
that was literally the next sentence out
of my
mouth just so everybody knows 20 years
ago making a million is the way people
talk about making a billion it was that
not achievable for almost everyone yeah
and now we all walk around and these
kids are
confused like the okay so America very
rich country country one of the richest
in the world if not the richest I don't
know where it sits with China these days
M the top 1% of earners in America the
bottom the last person in the top 1% the
top 1% is 440,000 a year that's wow
that's really let me say real
slow if you make more than $440,000 a
year you're in the top 1% of people in
America n man that is crazy and this is
where this is this is why these
conversations matter some kids listening
right now who thinks if he doesn't make
a 100 million he's a loser a million not
Sig this deal for less than a million
I'm not signing and not to cut into your
story but you're seeing a lot of that
content nowaday where it's like if you
don't have then you're this type content
I don't know why I'm seeing so much more
but let me let me tell you to and
straight it's not like we didn't have
that everyone's like oh we have it so
tough right now everyone's saying this
well we had less content there was no
Gary ve talking real [__] and what we
had was MTV Cribs and guess what yeah
all as if all of a sudden the world is
pushing like stuff it's been pushing
stuff always and we had no other things
to find they've been telling Lifestyles
of the Rich and Famous was a Smash Hit
in the80s Robin
Leech British Bo telling me as an
American seven-year-old boy like if I
don't have a yacht I'm a dick you know
like so it's been there the difference
is I see it flip everyone's like oh
social media did I'm like I see the flip
at least we now have people saying other
[__] facts because chains and bottles
and models and prob they've been pushing
that indeed facts indeed indeed yeah so
um yeah uh made made it made quote
unquote a million but in property by by
26 27 they lost it by 28 credit CR
happened credit CR happened I lost my
contract you you were overleveraged yeah
and I was and I was I was young so you
didn't know yeah and and I I had an
installation company I was making a lot
of money but I I just didn't have I was
making so much money I didn't have
saving yeah and I didn't have the the
kind of people around me to be like look
this is business I I just went straight
into it I feel like that usually happens
with every business man that crash and
burn a little bit just to really learn
how to really manage your Finance I'm
really happy you said that it's why I
want to talk about [__] that I talk
about yes is right the business man and
woman the 80% that's about the stuff the
20% that are about the game never have
that happen right cuz they're not buying
dumb [__] they're not over leveraging
three properties because they know if
God forbid it goes I'm at zero right
they're not buying [__] to flex like the
amount of people that want to be rich
just to buy stuff to impress people that
they don't even like right it's
crazy you want to talk about a model
that's [__] up the amount of people
that want to be rich at all costs and
[__] their lives up just to buy [__]
right
to flex on people that they don't even
like they don't even know don't even
know don't even know exist for but
what's funny is people Flex for someone
they know let me say yes but it's always
to show the girl that didn't give you
that time show your dad that didn't give
you that love show your mom that said
you would never amount to nothing show
show
somebody then there's people that are
about the process this is why I was so
happy I was built properly I didn't do
that [__] right this is why like the
Gary like I don't even give a [__] about
me I you know why I like the Gary ve
thing for my parents right they built me
what the [__] did I do I didn't have sex
they had sex I popped out I didn't I
didn't you know you know like for y'all
I they you know for for y'all I'm saying
stuff and maybe I can have an impact but
they did me so like when they're like
you're the greatest I'm like you mean
Sasha and Tamara vaynerchuk yeah they
made me New Jersey made me IM immigrant
life made me I it's definitely like so
important to what you were saying just
like when you said who your environment
and to your point when you said watch
who you're around because especially for
a lot of black entrepreneurs or black
businessmen depending on environment not
every black person but um depending on
environment there's a lot of times when
we make that breakthrough into wow this
is working wow I'm actually bringing in
some income we don't necessarily have
yeah an environment that tells us hey
you need to put this amount of money
away of course black comma anyone who
doesn't come from an environment of
money facts in 20 years you'll be
hearing a lot of people saying it from
Latin backgrounds I came up in the hoods
of Texas and Arizona like it's all it's
whoever at the like it just it's a money
thing and by the way a lot black white
hispanic like gender race religion
sexual orientation it's the people
around around you this is the point of
why I think this is a special era
everyone's telling you that all this
[__] on this phone is garbage and yet
the only good stuff is found on the
phone yeah you definitely got a f for
yourself turn on the TV and tell me
what's so
incredible that's helping the youth true
chat first first time coach Lori cash
the nukes like please Twitter cuz twitch
is live tell me this incredible TV show
that's raised in the kids right cuz I
can show you YouTube channels I can show
you Instagram I can show you Tik Tok of
people putting it down proper Lear tell
me the [__] TV show give me the
newspaper the radio program get the [__]
out of here with this [__] yeah
that's a good point like I get they the
reason people are [__] on all this
stuff is cuz it's where everyone's
paying
attention like I'm I'm you know what is
TV you
know someone said ESPN I I'll give you
that of course way I I'll counter that
Sports now has these Talking Heads
[__] on guys constantly yeah I'm
about say ESPN report injuries before
they post anything what Jason kid said
the other day about the uh about and
ESPN has Talking
Heads trying to get people to watch
which and there's a lot of good dudes
and ladies on ESPN I know a lot of them
they don't even they don't even realize
what's happening they're in the con they
come in innocent they're like I need
ratings they don't realize how it
metabolizes and you start trying to be
positive and you're like ah my ratings
aren't you say one thing about somebody
like and then we're getting
seduced by rubbernecking when you're
driving you're not paying attention when
there's not an accident but when there's
an accident you're looking yeah that's
true and so the media figured that out
and they're shoving all this garbage
down our [__]
throat this toxic that accident thing
just hit me that's kind of crazy down a
little bit you got me with the accident
this is why I'm fighting so hard this is
why I'm fighting so hard to like the
good [__] we got to figure out how to
make the good [__] given flowers when
we're live saying what I said to you
like act people the reason you remember
that is people don't do that [__] we got
to figure out a way collectively all 8
billion of us and definitely the few of
us that are so fortunate to just be good
MH we have I always say negativity is
loud as [__] good at marketing and
positivity is silent no seriously and
the reason I'm so [__] loud is I'm
like well I can only control me yeah I
can't tell all of you to do it if I
don't do it mhm right yeah that I think
what really help me there's a quote
everything speaks and it's like from the
clothes that you wear to how you carry
yourself to the music you listen to
everything you consume everything
everything speaks what are you saying
and when I heard that quote I was like
wow like okay my words are are this some
of my actions are this but that's saying
something completely different than what
I stand for like so I had to evaluate
myself and once I became extremely
intentional and had intent behind every
action that I made and I started
tracking my own actions I started seeing
results like to your point with social
media it's like I actually started
unfollowing accounts that were posting
crazy stuff let's about that when people
like these feeds are all [__] up I'm
like
you sunshine and roses and honestly when
you really believe in like manifestation
you really don't have any time for
negative energy anyway you come back and
people like oh manifestation is [__]
I'm like manifestation is slang for
being intentional exactly that's all
I I manifested I'm like no you took
those seven meetings you did that work
like it's not like you sat and prayed
and [__] just dropped true true it's all
part of the process for real quick
actually let's open up a pack of be
friends cuz this is podcast with friends
um while we're opening this [__] tell me
what you're paying attention to tell me
something that caught your
eye in the world recently what's
something that's like really popping
really popping right now like yeah
something oh [__] you hit a monster
what's that
oh let's [__] go Gary you're going to
have to tell me more about this I tell
you more about this in minute I don't
want to act like I'm like oh I just got
the unicorn and I don't know what that
means exactly this is this is my Pokemon
meets Sesame Street thing I'm building
called vs I'm building it for the rest
of my life it's a bunch of characters
you pulled the gritty ghost hearing how
you came up this one really hits right
for you so you got to hold on to that
and it's out of only a 100 this is a big
car that's not fair that's real money
what was going
another real money what would you no no
here's
the I want you to look at the characters
the names tell me which character most
resonates with you which character when
you look at it I'm going to go first I'm
going to say the adaptable alien CU I
think one of my greatest skills is being
adaptable the reason I [__] with people
so much is I'm not scared of people any
people I'm around different I look I got
very lucky I grew up in Edison New
Jersey I went to Martin Luther King
Elementary School we had a real Melting
Pot you already know when it's MLK exact
so it was black but I had it better than
black white Indian Asian Brian Chen was
my friend in third grade Robert Lee then
Nati halel like we I we had it all like
you know I didn't know I was a kid when
I got older especially in the last 10
years where you realize diversity
matters I'm like damn not only did I
have the great parents I had the great
environment I learned how to love
everyone we were just all mixed crazy
like I don't like I actually have it on
my Instagram my second grade picture
when I posted that people were like oh
you weren't kidding because literally
there's 20 kids in a class and it's like
four of these four of these four of
these four of these and four of these
and that's just a [__] gift right you
know anyway so I'm going to go adaptable
alien okay whether I'm talking to the
biggest CEO in the world or I'm in a
third world country building a school
for pencils of promise and everybody in
between I'm just good with people so
adaptable how for you I'm I'm going to
go with great
ghost what does grip mean for you um
hard work man hard work and just just
being do you think the world's
demonizing hard work a little bit right
now don't burn out oh no 100% 100% but
balance is Right Real Talk balance is
right don't burn out but do you think we
maybe go a little far where like like a
little bit of entitlement a little bit
of lack of balance like people trying to
win without putting the eff this is I'm
I'm I'm not saying this just for I'm in
love with hard work I just I just love
hard work my parents worked there all
the way you know so yeah I just I just
love it which one my guy I'm going to go
right here with the with the graceful
goldfish yeah why and just because
everything I've ever done everything I'm
doing everything that I'm going to do uh
I try to approach with a real level of
professionalism and just and just grace
and grace you know and um this is why I
love this [__] dudes that are cool say
saying the word Grace yeah is is
literally the mission statement of my
life watching this man right now notice
how even he's like you know profession
no no Grace I'm on something like what
our grandmas liked is now right meaning
like Grace like respect my big thing
right now that I'm hot on is we're
putting youth on a pedestal and we're
underestimating wisdom and age 50 years
ago the elders had all the respect and
the kids had nothing now we flipped it
cuz of Technology social
act said D you it I think we need to get
back to like resp people0 to 100 on the
way they earned it real talk we I watch
people at the airports we are just
losing our [__] yeah like not getting up
for like I watched these three dudes
just sitting there nice I they weren't
Bad Dudes but the fact that a grand I
watched it I watched it cuz I'm on it so
I'm looking yeah this 85-year-old lady's
walking by them you could tell I was
like behind I was was standing doing a
call before the airport this is like 2
weeks ago 3 weeks ago and these dudes
are just chilling not bad not like out
of a movie where they're like thugs
they're just normal dudes but this
85-year-old lady is like clearly like
tired like it's just clear like she's
like looking and I wasn't even mad at
the dudes real talk I was just mad at
where we're at 40 years ago all three of
those dudes would have been like right
yeah we just don't teach I even say my
my biggest inspiration um just as far as
like media goes I my favorite show ever
was a different world just because of
obviously I went to an HBCU and that was
all about that but just the way they
looked and the way they acted the way
they talked on it was just so it was
just so much more professional and
graceful dog C says why can't someone
cool say grace everyone cool can say
grace please tell me the last time
you've seen a 15 to 25-year-old cool
person talk about Grace is important we
don't talk about Grace now we got a
different slang tour for it maybe
respectful like there's some other
places but it's everybody can say
anything they want I'm saying what we're
not it's not 23y olds that are popping
in Social aren't making content around
manners that's what I'm saying that's
facts cool Grace I love that you did
that bro graceful goldfish man shout out
to the Goldfish out goldish goldfish are
a great snack so I'm going go with
that all so I noticed this guy had the
highest score so that gravitated me
towards it but then I read it and it
says thoughtful three-horned harpi um so
I am trying to be I I actually had two
have one amazing parent but had two
amazing parents that raised me who
taught me that purpose is above all and
so growing up I relate to a lot of
things you said because I at a young age
was thinking through like well that
doesn't really align with what I believe
in or what I want for my life so I'm not
going to do that right it made saying no
so much easier for me so once you know
how to say no to things the yes becomes
more clear so thoughtful because I'm
trying to be as thoughtful as possible
right now I just started trying to make
content that I knew wouldn't perform
well that just mean something to me so
um I've actually I don't think I've made
a video about Grace but I have started
making like not not a podcast but um
where I'm just speaking on a microphone
just talking about things I number one
genre of content creation that no one's
doing right now in my mind is you have a
thought you're you not you don't have a
video person around you yet you're not
there yet you don't really love doing
the video like this cool hit the memo
talk save post that [__] right words
radio right [__] Works still that's
crazy yeah it's that's true I do see
that a lot like if you got a thought
that you believe in pop it record it you
could put some video on top of it later
or just post it I think someone's going
to own that and it's going to make it
easier for people but I love that big
shout out to the heart pick here's the
big one you ready for this there's 283
be friends it's a big world there's only
one madeup character everything else is
something you know an alien a wombat an
otter a ghost a worm a duck right the
only character I drew and made up is the
harick the harick whoa ladies and
gentlemen come on chat talk to me ni
go what I look like
now let's go what uh what else is
happening in the game that's caught your
eye that you're confused about that
you're thinking through that you're
being thoughtful about or give some
roses this is the one I love a lot cuz
this shit's so fun to look at 5 years
later how about somebody coming up that
you see M that you see that's a good
question let me so my the first thing
that popped to my head is just what what
is what I'm becoming more aware of more
than anything is the shift in what works
so okay what I mean by that is think
about sneakers and we were talking about
this off camera by the way somebody just
said I'll buy that goes for 15 $5 right
oh my I'm going to hold
on you got let me just let me just tell
you what just happened let me just tell
you what just happened that's when you
know someone's from the streets when
someone doesn't know the value of
something gets thrown something real at
them but their instincts are like nah
you know some [__] I don't so I'm going
to hold this [__] and where' you get
that number from 155 that's kind of
precise I tell you where I think they
got it from I I don't know if you've
seen but I always do this in every photo
I take because my mom knitted me a
jersey when we couldn't afford a Jets
Jersey when I as a kid and put the
number five on it so every photo I ever
take as a head nod to my mom and as a
homage to her and how she built me and
why people even want to take photos with
me is because of her I throw up the five
as a little token so you locked in over
there so everybody knows in the five a
thing like even some of these Char I
don't know if we got any but some of the
characters even have like a five this is
number 55 right here actually okay there
you thece so anyway that's probably why
but anyway I'm sorry go ahead no so I we
were talking off camera and like the
hype era of sneakers is is is dead and I
think when I'm looking at social media
I'm looking at content the era of doing
the wild thing to get attention I can
see it sh shifting look if they're good
at it Mr Beast is crazy that's just
going to work that's a lot of talent
behind that's a lot of thought that's a
lot of planning that's a lot of
effort all that's different
I'm referring more to the the content
that lacks any sense of death from any
standpoint whether creatively where it's
just going you know what it's called
supply and demand right we got filled
with that yes and so now we're looking
for something else right yeah um you
know something I would like to or a
person I love giving flowers keep
thinking that's what I really wanted to
I'm going to get back to that but um
just personally right now what I would
like to see is that with all of these I
don't want to say kids but just this
next Generation coming up so fast and
doing all these things I would like to
see them even give like you know how we
have like master classes from you know
RS or whoever I would like to see them
start teaching the kids below them now
about just teaching now we have these 19
you know about J Alpha exactly so J
Alpha's coming right exactly I think
they're they're still debating what the
year is cuz that's what they do but call
them 13 and under right okay okay
they're coming next and they they're
going moving faster than than we did
interesting the early signs cuz I'm
spending a lot of time reading this the
early is they got judgment for Gen Z
right Jen Alpha's it's so crazy how fast
it all moves Jen alpa's coming out
saying yo gen Z you talk big game but
you're full of [__] right you got to
give the codes man you got to give the
codes that's crazy crazy is crazy
nine-year-olds looking at their
16-year-old crying about some [__] but
not doing [__] right you got to get a
that's why I would love to see them
teach bro it's that next Generation yeah
cuz we have these 19 20y old
millionaires from you know building all
this content and they're literally
building their own websites and you know
there building their own Enterprises and
Empires and everything just really just
come down just give the codes to to the
Next Generation I think it be cool it's
been the story of my life I I I would I
actually I've never read my own book of
course not I wrote it I know what in it
lately crush it which I wrote in 2008
came out in 09 lately I'm like man
should I like read it just to like
refresh ideas because the [__] I talked
about there of like this internet thing
and like you should do YouTube and like
I predict that people will make $100,000
a year on YouTube everybody read it back
then and was like you're a [__] idiot
like like you know like like and all I
was when I look at all those books when
I think about what this this comes out
I've never tried harder to give
everybody all the cheat codes right cuz
it feels it creates admiration it
creates real relationships what else are
you seeing oh cool um what's going on in
London oh man so I I I just want to
shout out someone someone that you know
actually um uh Dexter Muller M yeah yeah
so he's doing some big things in London
man I want to give him his flowers man
he's he's really grind in so yeah I just
want to give him his flowers but in
London what's happening now I
mean it's a it's a Melting Pot I I would
say people are I think people are
searching for the next thing if I'm
honest what we're all saying yeah I
think people are searching for the next
thing something you can feel it we're on
the Cur feel you can feel it it's
changing I agree and yeah that's kind of
yeah go we were talking about this and I
was talking to Tyler about this too and
he was speaking about you and how just
always staying ground to kind of feel
what's coming be in the dirt there's a
there's a there's a v friend character
none of us pulled it I don't see it here
it's called it's a long ass name you
can't beat a worm from the dirt
seriously CRA that is the name of the
character that's crazy so and like
that's who I think I am for all the
hardcore V friends trading cards fans
like here's the alpha story that you've
been looking for obviously in vriends
there's Gary B the be and like that's
two on the nose that's me but that's not
really me in V friends in V friends the
character I made for me who's me is you
can't beat a worm from the dirt it's the
same [__] what Tyler was probably
telling you and that's cool that he was
telling you that is like no matter
whatever happens with me I'm always
going to be in it I'm always going to be
what what did I say to y'all what have
you been up to I've been operating I'm
not saying I'm a businessman I'm a
businessman and then I'm going to tell
you about it yeah I'm never going to I'm
never going to get high on my own Supply
I just told you I don't even think it's
me it's very easy for me to stay humble
I don't think I did anything I think my
parents did something one of the reasons
I want to shine is get people to get
some stuff but also I know it makes my
parents feel like I am I get that like
and so I'm in the dirt I'm never going
to think I'm better than somebody cuz
I'm not I got skills I got things so
does
everybody the dirt is where it this you
know in music when the streets don't
[__] with you you left the dirt right
yeah that's usually how it goes that's
out of 10 you left the dirt now that's
not saying like what we you know the
other saying that we all know is like
rappers get killed in their Hometown I'm
not saying you shouldn't if you're in a
real bad neighborhood like I'm not
saying that but I'm saying like are you
putting people on are you watching the
kids come up yeah are you giving a
cosign right are you giving somebody a
feature on your track just cuz you
actually [__] with them and you see
yourself in them the [__] am I doing
right now that's true I want the three
of you to siphon attention thank you man
real talk I'm hoping y'all say something
that makes a 100 people a thousand
people 10,000 people over next year be
like yo I like the way he talked what
was his handle again actually let's do
that how do people find you uh you can
find me at Christian Crosby on all
socials I have the same Christian c h r
i s t i n Christian spelled normal
Crosby c r o SB y all right yeah uh
Chase B find me on all socials at OG
Chase B man how's it B not like mmy B oh
no chase b b
um and yeah every time I say Gary ve
they're like B every time say B and
[__] up you got to real I say V as inv
Victor when I call like credit it's VY
I'm like V is inv Victor ay any I gota
always do it cool um yeah Franklin king
of trainers king of trainers everywhere
um you might even see in JD Sports but
before we get out of here cuz they
haven't pulled me yet which is good cuz
I at 2:00 I'm enjoying this uh tell me
which social media platform you are
struggling with
like you're you wish you were making
content for it or you wish you were
making better content for it cuz you
want to be good at it if you don't if if
it doesn't exist don't make it up but go
ahead oh yeah go
YouTube you where are you at with
YouTube shorts um I just started YouTube
shorts is the gateway drug to build
attention to then give you the leverage
to do YouTube proper right okay probably
just Tik Tok you know it's something
that um I enjoy it a lot but I'm not
utilizing it the way could be so yeah
just TI are you posting on it at all a
little bit but it's more most of it is
like actually like produced content and
people are kind of off that when it com
T they want let me give you one on this
do you [__] with live at all have you
ever done live with fans I've done it
before let me tell you right now this
for everybody this is the alpha for
everybody Tick Tock live yeah live
shopping is coming it's huge in China
people just selling [__] on live Tik Tok
wants to win it not a lot of people
going live on Tik Tok they are fully
fully fully creating discoverability for
the people that are doing it mhm I don't
give a [__] what you do on it eat cereal
and just talk to them all right like get
your ass on Tik Tok live right okay push
yourself I know it's not I know natural
I know I see it in you but bro honestly
just like put it there and just like it
could be anything like if you're going
to listen to music for an hour then just
go on Tik Tok live and just look over
I'm doing right now and be like yo mix
one two three go what's good Jenny H
thank you so much you know what I mean
mhm um to be honest there isn't actually
um a platform I'm actually the one of
the people that started live selling
back in the day um but I want to kind of
say there's another platform coming eBay
live eBay live is coming come way just
say anything you know just say live it's
all
coming live Amazon live they're all
building they're all building live
shopping in America and in Europe is on
a precipice of complete explosion
complete me too with TV back in 2006 but
you know the way these platforms are
built for live shopping we wish we had
this this is it no friction click click
click you see that video of that woman
in in China that was just like passing
the
400,000 hours got swag too I'm not going
to lie she knows what she doing
with thank you so much for being on for
thank you twitch for watching podcast
with friends we will see you next time
[Music]